it's become an all too common scene
protesters gathering outside food
producing factories to demonstrate
against constantly rising prices in
argentina
a monthly average inflation rate of
around 5 percent is making it difficult
for people in the country to get by
the situation is very bad every day the
prices go up poor people do not have the
right to eat meat and we have no rights
and we want this to change the
government needs to control the prices
seriously
argentina has been battling high
inflation for years but in the past
months the prices of food have soared
making it difficult for many of the
families that have come here to make
ends meet the government of alberto
fernandez has been trying to find
balance between the different demands of
argentina's society but it has not been
easy and people here say that it has not
been working for them
social tension is on the rise this week
dozens of truck drivers blocked the
roads to protest against diesel
shortages across the country
one driver was killed when hit by a
stone as he tried to defy the protesters
and break through a roadblock
we are demanding that they let us
continue working we are demanding that
they give us fuel that they respect a
price and that they respect the rates
that they increase our freight rates a
little for our job right
argentina's economy is in the red
inflation is pervasive the government
has to spend billions of dollars a year
on energy from other countries
even though argentina has one of the
largest shale oil and gas reserves in
the world
conflict within the ruling coalition
complicates plans to find solutions
former president and now vice president
christina fernandez the kirchner has
been openly criticizing president
alberto fernandez on almost every
decision he has taken concerning the
economy
the latest pat was over a proposed gas
pipeline from the rich vaca muerta
reserve in patagonia
and on energy subsidies for the middle
class
right now we should be exporting energy
food and everything else and the war in
ukraine should benefit us like world war
ii they are discussing about a pipeline
but we are on an absurd situation with a
fight within the government on every
aspect of the economy that only
increases the attention
attention that extends from government
officials to the streets as people
continue to demand solutions that the
government seems unable to provide
teresa al jazeera buenos aires